I think this is certainly the biggest
season that we've ever had and the
most challenging terms of just the
overall scope of the show last year was
level three this is like skipping to
level seven it's intense
It was huge for the season in terms of
those initial rainstorms was just
knowing that this is the kids last
summer before high school
It was an emotional time and scary time too
because you didn't know what the future
was gonna hold so we wanted to use that
as an anchor for sort of the character
development this season
if season two was about the quest to get
back to normal season three is about the
inevitability of change we see our kids
in season three really wrestling with
that transition to adolescence and the
fact that that invariably does mean
leaving some things and maybe some
people behind we're not kids anymore I
mean what did you think we're just gonna
sit my basement all day and play games
for the rest of our lives
there was this seed planted early on in
season one of Joyce and hopper having
had a relationship in the past
I've always kind of wanted to see what
that was or how that came to fruition
and this season we start to see much
more of that I want you to feel like
this can still be your home relationship
between Joyce and hopper I think is
really fun and sort of complicated and I
think there's a lot there that we've
been sort of discovering each season
like we have history
kind of opens him up as a man and it
allows him to be vulnerable in a way
that he never has been in the show yet
it's a very interesting new dynamic
even though maybe you didn't grow up in
Indiana I do feel like people can relate
to having these ordinary lives
and this an excitement of that adventure
might just be around the corner
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new stranger things
season 4 video they just dropped a new
trailer in a featurette because it's the
one-year anniversary of the premiere of
season 3 they talked a lot about what's
going on during season 4 so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course I'll be doing videos
for the season 4 episodes and I will
talk about what's going on with that
because of all the delays they're going to
be filming again really soon they've
been a lot of questions about season 4
actually happening yes they are making a
season 4 I'll explain what the producers
said about that too because everyone's
wondering if there'll be more stranger
things after this season we learned that
the title of the first episode is the
Hellfire Club because of this tweet
that's probably a reference to 11 and
her friends the main group of characters
maybe it's the name that they give
themselves after getting back together
they split up briefly at the end of the
season for summer break when school got
out that's kind of what you see them
talking about during this like the kids
growing up is they're slowly driving
away at the end of the season there's
this whole theme in the show the last
couple of seasons about them growing up
becoming more mature taking more control
over their destiny
so maybe they reform the group to save
hopper and stop the Russians in a much
bigger way because it's implied that
they're leaving town they're going to be
heading to Russia or at least heading
into the upside down to fight the mind
flayer we get a much better look at Jack
and Hegar from Game of Thrones playing
what seems like one of the
administrators of this Russian prison
camp that hopper is stuck in he
typically plays assassins and really
badass killers on the other shows that
he appears on too
he kind of did that during Game of
Thrones so he definitely plays to a type
so it seems like he is the level up
villain from the Russian Terminator
character last season that hopper went
toe to toe with in the finale if it
wasn't clear because stranger things is
all about parodying in referencing 80s
pop culture movies and TV shows this guy
was supposed to be a version of Arnold
Schwarzenegger Terminator from the first
movie everyone press F in the chat for
Alexei and speaking of funny
coincidences David Harbour had a lot of
scenes with Alexei during stranger
things season 3
David Harbour's character in The Black
Widow movie is also named Alexei here's
what's gonna happen
Natasha don't slouch I'm not slouching
you're going to get a big hug mother oh
my god enough all of you it didn't say
that's not fair he's playing Red
Guardian but his real name is Alexi so
it's just a funny coincidence that he's
playing Alexi after having all these
scenes in stranger things season 3 with
Alexi I know everyone's wondering how
hopper wound up in a Russian prison at
the end of the season after that big
blast if he didn't travel through the
upside-down portal right now the most
common sense theory is that everyone was
probably disoriented from the blast long
enough for the Russians who did survive
the blast to grabbed him in the
confusion before anyone like Joyce could
notice or take the time to look around
the facility by the time the police and
military made it down there it had been
long enough for the Russians to pack up
everything that was left including that
that white demagogue and that they
teased and then take them back to Russia
they probably just grabbed hopper to
keep him from talking to the authorities
and reveal exactly what they've been
doing next big question why are the
Russians constructing railway tracks in
the middle of Siberia probably to build
a path so that they can hold their heavy
equipment to another site where the
barrier between dimensions in the upside
down is weakened up and they can try and
open another portal there early
prediction that'll probably be where xi
and the others face off against the mind
flayer for the last time the whole idea
of season 3 is that the russians were
causing a lot of problems because they
were trying to reopen another gate to
the upside down so the mind flayer will
probably try to take advantage of that
to break in to our dimension again
hopefully because we're talking about
big 80's references here they might use
that as an easter egg for the real world
Chernobyl explosion the big nuclear
meltdown so there's some disaster that
happens at the end of season 4 with the
mind flayer battle in this other portal
the rest of the Russian government might
try to hide their actions by covering it
up as a fake nuclear meltdown and so
that nobody will go to the site and poke
around
oh it's radioactive there's all this
fallout you can't go check and see what
happened there if you follow the
stranger things writers on their Twitter
account - they've also tweeted a lot of
the movies that inspire the season 4
storyline and they're all basically
Prison Break movies I'm a fugitive from
a chain gang Papillon The Great Escape
which is an awesome Steve McQueen movie
still acts 17 in Shawshank Redemption
even if you haven't seen all those
movies you've probably seen at least one
or two of them I don't think I need to
explain the plots of those because basic
concept that they all share in common is
that people are stuck in prison in
either trying to or successfully
breaking out
surely that's what this season 4 trailer
footage is trying to set up hopper being
stuck on Russian chain gang in the
middle of Siberia during the dead of
winter and either trying to escape
himself or looking for help from other
inmates or escaping with the help of 11
and the other kids even though all the
younger kids are noticeably older than
the previous seasons
they're still just barely approaching
high school so if they go to Russia they
still need the help of someone like
Joyce or the teenagers at least like
Steve and Robin and even though they're
the ones that stayed back in town like
Stephen Robin they will be main
characters during season 4 again if
anyone was worried that there were
people that weren't coming back for
season 4
Billy was really the only part of that
major group that was confirmed dead at
the end of the season and they could
always bring him back as a hallucination
in people's minds so for the most part
everybody is coming back but here's the
thing about season 4 in the possibility
of a season 5 because everyone's
wondering how they're going to end
stranger things what's the finale going
to be so in an interview the duffer's
said one thing but then the producer
Shawn Levy kind of said another
so the Deaf's claimed that the series
would be a four season thing and then
out meaning that they planned to end it
after four seasons but then their
producer Shawn Levy said that we're
definitely doing four seasons but
there's also the possibility very much a
possibility of a fifth season so I think
a lot of that just depends on their
filming schedule because the kids are
aging up so fast that they want to try
and get these out as quickly as possible
so there was some rumors a while ago
about them trying to film seasons four
and five back-to-back but I haven't
heard any confirmation on that it is the
possibility that yes there could be a
season five which is why you haven't
heard Netflix say anything about a final
season yet they could also wind up doing
a stranger things movie to wrap up the
series if they don't want to do a full
season five but one of the huge
differences from season three is they
revealed all their episodes scripts here
in this post and if you look at the
stack here zoom in enhance there are
actually nine different scripts meaning
nine different episodes for season four
instead of the traditional aid they did
do nine episodes during season two but
that extra one was kind of four Elevens
field trip so I'm just assuming that the
extra episode during season four is just
to give them extra time with the story
to wrap up everyone's arcs if they don't
do a season five but it does sound like
everyone's hopeful that they will
because the series seems like it's more
popular than ever we probably won't find
out about that for
while and if they do push to a season
five that would also mean that they
don't have their final battle against
the mind flayer at the end of season
four there's something that pushes them
into a big battle on the upside-down for
season five they're gonna be filming
again really soon but they only film for
about three weeks before they had to
shut down because of the virus so maybe
we'll see you season four episodes by
April or May next year but I'll be sure
to do an update video if Netflix post
anything official about that everyone
click here for my last big stranger
things season 4 trailer video and easter
eggs and click here to learn all about
Michael Keaton coming back as Batman in
the DC movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!